as a Souls focused Creator I can do
nothing but recommend lies of P to any
fans of the genre it's a great game and
probably the greatest Souls like ever
made it isn't shy about showing off its
influences and most of the game is in
one way or another directly inspired by
fromsoft Design I don't think there is
another game currently out that comes as
close to matching the soul series
experience and before we get too far
into why I want to note that the actual
Souls games don't count when ranking
Souls likes I'm not raiding lies of P
against any of The Originals games made
by frontsoft aren't Souls like they're
just souls or born akiro Rings just like
how Doom isn't a doom clone it's just
Doom so lies of p is very obviously a
Soul's like and it's one more committed
to fitting that mold than nearly any
other game in my opinion level
exploration is Rife with curling paths
that lead to doors and ladders which
become shortcuts the gameplay is
centered around stamina consumption and
monitoring though it is a bit less
tactical than say Dark Souls 1 because
everything is much faster paced your kit
features a guard which functions like
the Perry insecuro and a Dash and rally
heel a lot bloodborne there's weapon
upgrading through stones found in the
game World Plus special weapons that are
attainable from boss drops if you don't
use that boss drop to gain some leveling
and chop currency here called Ergo there
are equippable amulets found throughout
the game which do a range of things from
increasing stats and resistances to
buffing damage towards certain enemies
there are healing items which recharge
on death or resting that can be upgraded
in number and power there are tons of
surprise enemy attacks around corners or
from ceilings or in tight rooms and of
course there is a large emphasis on the
game's boss fights I could go on but
this should show How Deeply lies of P
commits to the genre formula and while
there are tons of examples of this I
should point out that there are areas
where the game goes in its own Direction
too for instance armor is not a thing
all your outfit choices are purely
fashion oriented armor and resistance
stats are determined by additional
equippables the weapon system is also
unique with every normal weapon having a
blade and handle which can be separated
to mix and match between all of them I
would say that the upgrade system which
is done through the collectible quartz
item is also different as it gives a
kind of skill tree only somewhat like
the one found in sekido Liza P also
features a much more active real-time
story that takes place while you play
the game unlike most of the souls games
which have more of their stories
relegated to lore and in that vein Liza
P also gives a bit of direction to its
NPC quests noting in menus when there's
an occasion to talk to somebody for some
advancement of a quest a feature very
much lacking in Souls games these
differences are there but even they
often prove the rule that Liza P
situates itself within the Soul's world
its departures are never strong enough
to break the feel of the formula so with
all these familiar elements and the high
production quality of the game I think
it's an easy argument to say that lies
of p is the best execution of souls
elements in total outside of the
originating extended series there just
isn't another game that does so much
Soul stuff at a high level of quality
some areas I think it does especially
well would be as follows the music
largely because of the songs and the
record player being so good the enemies
which are punishing throughout the game
often able to chunk your health if you
don't pay them some mind the secrets of
which there are many defined on every
level and lastly the combat and boss
fights which to me feel like they hit
the zone of being difficult but
generally learnable once you do start to
learn you get into the flow or dance of
combat fromsoft is known for being great
at and this is furthered by the
quickness granted from the Dash step the
guard parry and the opportunity to gain
Health back while attacking so with
everything I've said I just don't see
other games matching lies a p in terms
of souls like quality the only other
game I think to bring up would be Neo
and I can't speak as much to neo2 since
I haven't played it but my experience
playing neo1 was great it just had more
things going in a different direction
like the more loot heavy RPG element and
the stand switching in combat I really
enjoyed Neo and I'm not weighing in on
overall quality between it and Liza P
but when it comes to souls likes lies of
PE sticks to the formula more and
therefore is better at giving that
particular experience Liza p is directly
emulating the soul series much more than
Neo is kind of more like Lords of the
fallen and Mortal shell now we do have a
new Lords of the Fallen coming out soon
but at least until then I think Liza P
currently stands as king of the souls
likes as such I would recommend it to
any enjoyer of the series or franchise
if you generally like the souls games
and bloodborne and sakiro I would find
it very odd if you didn't also like Liza
P granted there is no multiplayer so
that could be a deal breaker for some
but with the summon they give for boss
fights I simply think most fans will
enjoy the game and that's part of why I
think it deserves the title of greatest
Souls like it fits the expectations of
the genre more than any of it but
despite the grandiose title I think I
would actually enjoy Liza P more if it
was more different if it was less like
Souls we've been playing souls and souls
like games for years at this point hell
iron pineapple has probably played a few
hundred or thousand of them himself Liza
P does a great job with the formula but
some of my favorite parts of the game
were when they loosened up on those
rules there are endless door and Ladder
shortcuts but my favorite was an
exploding minecart in the baron swamp
the story progressing in real time and
letting our character be part of it was
a lot more lively than what we get in
the souls games too and obviously the
devs prioritized the unique weapon
system as a differentiating feature Liza
p is a great game and shows off skill
from the developers at neowiz and round
8. I think it would have benefited by
not sticking so closely to the
established Souls formula but it is an
impressive feat to do that formula as
well as they did and with such skill now
demonstrated I hope that future content
whether it's for lies of P or similar
games can Branch out the souls games are
beloved but I don't think the goal
should be just to emulate them instead
of a stand-in Recreation a puppet of a
kind I think the devs and anyone else
making a similar game should strive to
go even beyond that to create a real
Standalone experience that lives on its
own
I will be putting out more lies of P
content in the near future so subscribe
if you enjoyed this and want to see that
thanks to my patrons for their support
thanks to you for watching and see you
in the next video peace